this is such a delightful surprise you
get this role Olaf voice roll and it
becomes one of the most iconic voice
characters in like the unit it's
fantastic it's great it's crazy so my
question is I know that you have
daughters how do they react that you're
the voice of Olaf they must go nuts for
it these are young kids right they're
young kids and um they don't care no
they actually they do care what they the
problem is is that kids love to brag
about stuff so they go up to people who
don't really need to know this
information and tell them that I'm Olaf
and so I was shooting a movie uh called
pixels in uh thank you for the Applause
in uh
the people have spoken
uh same Academy voters who apparently
didn't vote for Adam Sandler uh thank
you uh so I I agree I agree with you
guys so we were in uh Toronto and my
daughters go up to these uh lovely twin
girls who are so well spoken and they
have these lovely British accents and my
kids are just like clumsy gag children
and they go up and they're like hey
guess what our daddy is Olaf and the
girls look at them and they're like oh
that's so lovely our our father is Roger
Federer
like I was like first of all you guys
probably shouldn't tell stranger
and second of all we have to go we just
lost that match are you ever tempted are
you ever in a situation where you're
tempted to be because you can't get you
know recognized for the role of Olaf can
you can you
like get tempted to tell people yourself
like are you in a situation where it's
like hey I'm I'm Olaf that's me so
that's what I would do I would be in
this I would be in theater saying you
like that that's me
such I feel like I'd be such a dick if I
did that all the time yeah I know but
yeah what I would do but this thing
that's the point I'm trying to make guys
I know you're in the middle of a show up
there on that stage but I'm Olaf
um I uh I was actually what do you mean
you don't have a table
[Applause]
before I met
I love that I'm still using puns even
when I'm aggressively I'm trying to get
that table so I was driving one day as I
do I drive and as one does thank you so
much to all the pixel fans out there so
I was driving one day and and my friend
my wife's friend looks at me and she
always loves to like push me and she
goes she goes look over there and we see
this minivan uh with this Asian family
in it not that that matters right there
could have been anything but they but
they were Asia uh and so she looks at me
and she goes look they're watching
Frozen and I said oh that's great and it
had just come out on DVD she goes you
have to tell them what do you mean she
goes you have to roll down your window
and tell them who you are they're
they're in the car next to you they're
in the car they're Asian they're not
small they're Asian I'm saying they're
in the car next week he's like why are
they this no uh yes and so they're in
the car next to me minivan yep and so
she's like you're a dick if you don't
tell the kids in the back
I hate this story so I I rolled down the
window and I start to say hey I'm and I
just see the wife turn to the husband
and go ah Drive
window goes up they literally like run a
red light to get away from me yeah and I
was so mortified you know what you have
to do then that's when you really need
to chase after them
give me my table